the year was 1971 an engineer named Bob
Thompson at BBN an American research and
development company later acquired by
Raytheon created the world's first virus
proof of concept dubbed the creeper
although credited and referenced by
various entities as the world's first
computer virus the creeper actually
exhibited the behavior of a war
I am the creeper and Catch Me If You Can
this is what the virus said and the
world was never the same with over 12
types of malwares and over 100 types of
viruses lurking around the network
channels of the internet waiting to curb
innocent users and exploit
vulnerabilities the 21st century saw a
tremendous growth in cyber crimes and so
did the need and demand for cyber
Security Experts hello everyone and
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
in this video we'll take a look at
malware's the bread and butter of
thousands of hackers globally and what
are its various types we'll dive deep
into understanding how each of these
malwares function and how they
differentiate from each other but before
that if you enjoy watching these videos
and find them attractive then subscribe
to our YouTube channel because we bring
the best videos for you daily also press
the Bell icon to never miss any updates
from Simply love as we know the demand
for cyber security personals is
skyrocketing so if you want to master
the field of cyber security then simply
learn postgraduate program inside the
security in collaboration with MIT is
clearly the right choice for you this
postgraduate program in cyber security
is designed to equip you with the skills
required to become an expert in the
rapidly growing field of cyber security
this cyber security program aims to help
you stay ahead of the latest cyber
security Trends key features of this
program simply learns postgraduate
certificate master classes from MIT
faculty featuring modules from mitscc
and EC Council access to ceh kit 25 plus
Hands-On projects and many more this
cyber security certification program
begins with introductory level skills
and then progresses to Advanced cyber
security Technologies
this program covers all the essential
skills you will need to become an expert
in the field of cyber security cyber
security is one of the top concerns of
businesses today in an industry from
securing data to anticipating cyber
attacks and placing enterprise-wide
safeguards to prevent them employers
worldwide are increasingly looking for
qualified cyber Security Professionals
to join so what are you waiting for find
the course link mentioned in the
description box below and enroll today
so without any further delay let's jump
directly onto our topic for the day so
let's start with what is malware malware
is a short form for malicious software
and it's like a sneaky digital Intruder
that infiltrates your device without
permission it's created by cyber
criminals who want to disrupt damage or
gain unauthorized access to your
personal information financial data or
even control your device remotely
think of malware as a digital bully
that's up to no good
so let's understand how does a malware
work
Step 1 intrusion malware sneaks into
your device through various entry points
like malicious email attachments
infected websites software
vulnerabilities or even through
removable storage devices like USB
drives
Step 2 is execution once inside the
malware starts executing its malicious
code it may install additional files
modify system settings or create hidden
processes in the background to evade
detection
step 3 is persistence to maintain
control over your device malware often
tries to establish persistence it may
create registered entries modify startup
settings or hide in system folders
ensuring it launches every time you boot
up your device
next step is exploitation malware takes
advantage of vulnerabilities in your
operating system applications on network
to spread its reach it may exploit
security weaknesses to propagate across
networks in fact other devices are steel
sensitive information
the step 5 is malicious activities now
that the malware has settled in it
carries out its intended actions
depending on its type this could include
stealing personal information capturing
keystrokes encrypting files displaying
unwanted ads or even hijacking your
device for cyber criminals remote
control
the next step is concealment malware
often employs techniques to hide its
presence and avoid detection it may use
rootkit technology to hide its files and
processes employee anti-analysis
measures or encrypt its communication
with command and control servers to
evade security measures the last step is
damage or profit ultimately malware aims
to achieve its malicious objective it
may cause damage to your system
compromise your privacy steal financial
information or create opportunities for
cyber criminals to profit have you ever
wondered how it feels to be a cyber
security expert after gaining a
certification so let's take a minute to
hear it out from our Learners who have
experienced massive success in their
career after taking the cyber security
course hi I'm Philip I'm 61 years old
and last year IOP skill with simply
learns postgraduate program in cyber
security after working 30 years in the
IIT sector in various different profiles
I'm happy to tell you that that I was
able to clear and pass my cissp and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course of course I must
say was packed with practical examples
it was led by highly skilled certified
instructors I worked with many companies
before the security analysts and the
architect on a contract basis but I
needed some stability which I got with
the job I just started with Infosys as a
cyber security consultant happened after
I took the course but first and foremost
I've been a learner be a learner first
now that we have a good idea of how does
a malware work let's understand the
different types of malware more than 12
types of malwarees are present in the
world today and each of them is
threatening to different extent so let's
discuss some of the most common and
hazardous malwares the first is virus a
classic Troublemaker that attaches
itself to a program or file replicating
and spreading across your system it can
corrupt or destroy data and even render
your device useless
the second one is warm a sneaky creature
that replicates itself and spreads
across networks causing congestion and
slowing down systems it can also exploit
vulnerabilities to gain unauthorized
access
the next one is Trojan Horse inspired by
the ancient greektale this malware
disguises itself as a legitimate
software tricking you into installing it
once inside it opens a back door giving
cyber criminals remote control over your
device
the next is ransomware this villainous
malware holds your data hostage by
encrypting it the Cyber criminals then
demand a ransom to restore access
leaving you feel like a character in a
digital hostage situation next is
spyware a nosy little malware that
secretly monitors your activities
collecting sensitive informations like
password browsing habits and even
keystrokes talk about an invasion of
privacy
the next one is adware
an annoying Troublemaker that bombards
you with unwanted advertisements pop-ups
and redirects it's like a clingy digital
salesperson that never takes no foreign
answer
so those are some of the truly menacing
types of malware but knowledge is power
so how can we protect ourselves from
these digital villains
the first step is keep your software up
to date regularly update your operating
system antivirus software and
applications these updates often include
security pages to fix vulnerabilities
use strong and unique passwords avoid
using common or easy to guess passwords
opt for a combination of letters numbers
and symbols next is be cautious while
you are online avoid clicking on
suspicious links downloading files from
untrustworthy sources or opening email
attachments from unknown senders stay
vigilant next one is install reputable
antivirus software
invest in reliable antivirus software
that can detect and remove malwares last
is backup your data regularly backup
your important files and data to an
external hard drive or cloud storage
that way even if your device gets
infected you can restore your files
anytime
so I guess you guys must have got a good
idea about what is a malware and how to
stay safe from a malware
so that's all we had for you in this
video we can call it a wrap now if you
still have any questions or doubts let
us know in the comment section below and
our team of experts will help you at
their earliest so thank you so much for
being here today we'll see you next time
until then stay safe and keep learning
with simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign